- What up, guys?
The other day I spoke
at a really interesting
food and agricultural keynote.
This is an incredible
keynote for a lot of people
in the B2B sector or the traditional
$100 million dollar plus business sectors,
this is a keynote that
you should forward to
a bunch of your dads and
grandpops and grandmas
and grandpas, it's just
a very interesting talk.
I felt, I mean this was,
I was really in the zone.
I hope you agree.
(uptempo music)
Morning.
Very, very happy to be here.
Really enjoyed the opening monologue.
In the context of today's morning,
I tweeted just now,
it's been interesting over
the last 72 hours whether
in a Wall Street Journal
interview or a business meeting,
now a conference, and a
lot of one-on-one meetings,
I've heard the same thing
about 11 or 12 times
and it struck me finally
this last time on stage
which is how many people
keep saying the word
or the sentence it's
changing, it's changing.
I think anybody here this morning
that hasn't fully quantified
how much has actually changed,
this has changed.
I think there is an
unbelievable disconnect
between the framework and strategy
of how we are running our businesses,
whether a B2B or B2C
environment on us calibrating
is it changing or has it changed?
And more importantly, the
practicality of the timing.
I spend very little time on
the impact of self-driving cars
in a micro, in a 24 or 36 month window,
but I try to understand and
quantify them in a macro.
And I think the thing that I've spent,
and I'm a real hardcore,
purebred entrepreneur,
just to give you guys context
on the cross lines here,
I was born in the Soviet
Union, came to the US,
lived in a studio apartment
half the size of this stage
with eight family members,
very old school, merchant upbringing.
My dad got a job as a
stock boy in a liquor store
and we saved all our dollars.
I'm super an enigma.
All the Russian Jews that emigrated
were straight A students.
I was a straight D and F student.
It's really interesting,
I'm extremely bitter now
because I was making
three to $4,000 a weekend
when I was 12 selling baseball cards,
'cause that was the cultural phenomenon,
but I was a loser because
I was getting Ds and Fs
because it was the late 80s, early 90s,
and the only ROI was the
college you were going to.
If I was making $4,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards today,
I would be the next Mark Zuckerberg
and on covers of magazines.
And so, I'm very fascinated by trends,
by things that happen,
but I think the thing
that has really worked
for me is I didn't realize
probably into the last decade,
I take a lot of pride when I
was an early investor a long,
two, three, four years
pre-IPO or acquisition
on things like Twitter and
Facebook and Venmo and Uber.
I'm not in the luck business,
I'm in the marathon running
business, and more importantly,
I'm in the timing business.
I'm so deeply actually consumer-centric
that I don't have any other gear.
The only thing I ever do
is try to reverse-engineer
the attention of my end consumer
whether in a B2C or B2B environment,
and I try to understand things like,
it blows my mind how many
people here feel comfortable
because they have long-term
contracts and relationships
with some of the biggest
companies in the world
without realizing that
those companies themselves
are so disproportionately
vulnerable, and I just,
I play with this, right?
I play with the fact that $80 billion
is spent on television commercials
on the Fortune 500 CPG brand side,
yet 94% of them lost market share
because not a human being on earth
watches a television commercial.
None.
And by the way, can we
all agree this is not
a 14 year old girl crowd, right?
We are a little bit
older here, but not old.
Everybody here has got plenty of time.
How many people, actually, you know what?
Let me frame up my entire talk here.
Before I go any further,
how many people in this room
are retiring within the next 10 years,
not because you're gonna
crush it and cash out,
but because you're actually just old?
(crowd laughing)
Just raise your hands.
Okay, all right.
So for the 13 of you, I think
there's a level of grain
of a salt that we can take going forward,
but for the rest of you, I
want to tell you something
that I really want to get across
as a framework to the strategy
of why this conversation
is disproportionately important and how,
and I work with companies,
like say, P and G
and a bunch of food service companies,
so I have a real sense
of context in this room.
I want to leave you with
disproportionate practicality
of why I think you need to
look at your marketing spend,
or more importantly, why you need
to start debating a marketing spend,
because if you are a
sales-driven organization
in a B2B environment, you are
disproportionately vulnerable,
so we need to talk about that.
But before we get into that,
here's why I asked that 10 year question.
Literally nothing we talk
about, or way more importantly,
literally nothing that
controls the attention
of our end consumer existed 13 years ago.
We need to take a big step back
in this room and understand
what we are talking about is
not social media or Snapchat,
what we are talking about is the maturity
of the internet itself, what
that means to the human race,
and everybody in this room, including me,
is so disproportionately misunderstanding
how substantial this shift is
and what happens over the
course of the next decade.
The internet is the middleman, period.
And it's maybe just not your turn.
It was the bookstore's turn first.
It was some guy or gal that
owned 13 medallions in taxis
in this city second or third.
It is the hotel rooms
and the supply and demand
of that world's turn today.
It is the media companies across
the board's turn right now
and it may be your business next.
Walmart's not gonna give you the contract,
Walmart's gonna have to do
it itself, they're gonna be,
they're gonna buy dairy farms,
they're gonna grow the grain,
everything gets shrunk.
And so we have to take a real step back
and understand that there
is only one thing, one,
there's one thing that will keep you
from being a commodity;
Your brand.
The only thing that will keep you away
from being completely
commoditized is your brand.
Can you create an environment
where somebody actually
makes an emotional decision
or a subconscious decision,
not a practical one?
Because if you're in the middle
and people are gonna
make practical decisions,
there's an enormous amount of
vulnerability in the system.
We are completely and utterly
controlled by this device
whether you like it or not.
Please, my friends, do not
make business decisions
because of your personal,
romantic point of view of technology.
The amount of people here that
will dictate their businesses
to failure because of their points of view
of when they go out, they find it sad
that people look at their phones
instead of talk to each
other is staggering to me.
And so look, this is real
disruption, this isn't ha ha,
this is over the course
of the next decade,
90, 80, 70% of the biggest
companies in multiple sectors
will not only decline
but completely diminish
and completely vanish.
I look at the fashion industry,
it's just so fascinating, literally,
they're all out of business.
The math is just not gonna work.
Every day, there are brands that go
from zero to $15 million in sales
on the back of influencers on Instagram
with no overhead or
infrastructure, at scale.
And the cut of those
thousand cuts is staggering.
And this all is on top of you can talk,
we can talk about food trends
and the behavior of the end consumer,
that's absolutely right, that's fine.
That is minor leagues
compared to the fundamental
human shifts we're going through.
Did anybody see the robot that
went viral on the internet
the other day?
There's a robot that was
doing twists and turns.
How many people, just raise
your hands, I'm curious.
Did you see what Elon Musk said about it?
Which was, so there's this robot,
you have the find this, I don't
have a lot of data on this,
so you know, it's in the feed,
in the headline reading society,
I don't like to talk
about things I don't know,
here's what I know.
A robot that scared the crap
out of me was in my feed.
Just doing stuff that makes
LeBron look like me, right?
Elon Musk decides to take that,
somebody more educated
in robotics than I am,
and said something very clever
and I know enough about
how he communicates
where he's like, "You think this is cute?"
In 24 or 36, I don't remember the timing,
very shortly, you won't even
be able to see this robot
without technology that
it would be so fast
that the human eye can't even see it.
Now why do I bring that up?
I bring that up because it's a proxy.
It's a proxy to the following.
Everybody in this room needs to realize
that we are about to run
an incredibly fascinating
business marathon,
and most of you aren't
even on the treadmill yet.
And let me explain.
The treadmill to me is
how you spend your money
on marketing and sales.
The one place that you
could leave here today,
walk out the door, fly home,
and do something about
what I'm talking about
is how you spend money to get revenue in.
I am fascinated by people in the B2B space
to think it's ROI positive to
buy booths and full-page ads
in B2B magazines in
2018 and not understand
how Facebook advertising works
to become a top of the funnel
conversion sales funnel
for their business.
I'm fascinated, I am fascinated
that a room like this
with as many successful
people as sit in these chairs
have unbelievable opinions
of Facebook advertising
without ever running a
Facebook ad in their lives.
You have a whole lot of
opinions based on stock prices
or a headline you read or
what the Wall Street Journal
wrote on the issue nine months ago,
yet you lack practitionership
to understand
exactly what's happening here.
And we are living through
the great divide right now,
my friends, of the headline readers
and the practitioners when it
comes to running businesses.
And by the way, that last line, society.
All these confusions of how
things are changing is the deep
either lack of interest to look at it
because it's so heady that
it's so scary to understand
how big of a shift this is,
or the naivete, or worst
of all, the audacity.
Every business that is CFO-driven,
short-term, 90-day-driven
financial arbitrage machines
are on-call because
they haven't quantified
that the ground that they're
standing on has changed
and that's been a stable
ground in consumer behavior.
Look, consumer behavior
is super interesting
for the last 70 years.
What we don't quantify is
that for the last 70 years,
the propaganda that made
you make business decisions
stayed the same.
It was print, television, radio,
direct mail, it was basic.
The internet is such a
harder place to navigate.
And what's interesting, and
let me take a step back,
to frame up what my passion
is my opening rant sits on,
I only have one move.
How many people here by show
of hands are familiar with
Mariano Rivera, the New
York Yankees pitcher
that pitched for 20 years?
I'm just curious, because
I want to use the analogy.
Okay, good enough, I'll use it.
20 years, closer for the Yankees,
goes down as one of the great
all-time players of all time,
the guy had one pitch.
We had others for the
baseball nerds in here,
but the fact the matter
is, he had one pitch,
and nobody could hit it.
Edgar Martinez from the
Mariners could hit it.
Nobody could hit it for 20 years.
And that's what I have.
I suck at most things, but
I will buy the New York Jets
and win seven Super Bowls,
which will cost me billions of dollars
because I have one pitch,
and is what I'm trying to shove down
the throat of this room which
is I day trade attention
and you better start
understanding what I mean by that.
I day trade attention.
No matter what you do in this room,
for the people presenting to
the most senior executive here,
whether you have a side
business when you go home
that you're passionate about,
which is selling jelly
direct-to-consumer on Amazon,
I don't know you and I don't
know what you're up to,
but let me promise you, the
one thing that I can talk about
that connects everybody here
and will bring value to everybody
is before you tell me
how good your thing is,
you need my attention.
Many rely on historic
natures of the business,
the sales funnel, the B2B
nature, the contracts,
the way it's been.
Others, 25% of this room
probably spend their time
thinking about the consumer.
How many people here actually
are in B2C businesses?
Raise your hands.
Just curious.
Just higher, if you don't mind,
because I want to navigate
my talk, thank you.
B2B.
The rest, okay.
I'm fascinated, let me
go very tactical on you
because I really want to go to Q an A,
so I want to set up as much framework,
but I'm gonna go a little tactical,
maybe it'll spur a question.
I'm watching SaaS companies
that have a million dollars
in funding create disproportionate wealth
by running Facebook ads
against the employees of segmentation.
I believe that a lot
of people in this room
don't understand that
their company can run ads
against the employees of an organization
they are trying to do business with.
That ad may say, "Does
your head buyer know,
"does your CIO know, does your CFO know
"the fact that I can run
ads that cost me $4 CPMs
"that are actually being consumed
"and that the creative of
the video or the presentation
"or the white paper or the paragraph
"or the image with words on it
starts with copy in the post
"that says does your blank
within your organization know
"which then leads to between
1.3% and 4% of people
"forwarding it to that
person whether janitor
"or C-suite co-worker?"
To then convert in top of funnel
is something I've never
seen in B2B in the 20 years
of being a practitioner in marketing,
both traditional and direct
mail and radio and television
and outdoor and digital,
my passion sits here today
because I know that Facebook
is the disproportionate
arbitrage for this room,
and I also am empathetic to know
why nobody would believe
that in a B2B environment
in this room, but it doesn't
make it any less true.
And because building my dad's business
from a three to a $60 million business,
which was a liquor store in New Jersey
over a five year window
with no dollars at all,
no cash infusion, no VC was very difficult
but the only reason I pulled it off
is because I day traded attention.
In 1996, I started an email newsletter
when nobody was doing that,
and I had 91% open rates
for the first four years
of my career, which is unheard of.
And then Google came out and
I bought wine terms on Google
for five cents a click from the word wine
to the word Silver Oak.
And when I hear, and it
wasn't in the bio here,
but a lot of times they're like,
"And he took his business
from three to $60 million",
I cringe in the corner before I come on
because I say to myself,
"It should have been 250."
And the reason it should have been 250
was because I was one
of the first advertisers
on Google AdWords because I was on there
the day it came out.
It was so grossly under-priced attention,
but I was too young to
understand that it was so big
that it was a once-in-a-lifetime,
a twice-in-a-lifetime,
maybe a three-times-in-a-lifetime
in my 60-year career
arbitrage to build wealth
on such underpriced attention.
I stand here with this energy
because I have a chip on my shoulder
because I'm mad that I
didn't understand it,
and that I spent money on
direct mail and print and radio
and sales and many other things.
How many people here play poker?
Raise your hands.
Thank you.
When you have the best
hand, you go all-in.
I had it, and I didn't.
The best hand as I stand here today,
and I could care less if it's not tomorrow
'cause I day trade is Facebook.
And you have to, at a bare minimum,
understand how to start
spending money in that world,
not because it's gonna be so
disproportionately ROI positive
for your business, though I
think any dollar spent there,
if you actually know how to do it,
will be better than what
you spend anywhere else,
it's because you need to start at the top,
creating a cadence to
understand how to market
and sell in the new
environment that we live in.
There is no way that you
will be an organization
that has success and
machine learning and AI
and any other things that are gonna happen
from 2020 to 2030 if you don't
understand how to communicate
in the mobile-first
environment that is today.
You will not have the
taste or understanding,
and to be very frank,
some won't even get there.
And so it's a very fascinating time
and the stakes are extremely high.
When I look at the businesses
in this room from afar,
when I look at the current marketplace,
I get enormous passion
because it's so avoidable,
but the problem is, even the
three people in this room
that are inspired and are
actually gonna do something
about this will outsource it
and not become the
practitioners themselves
which will then create the vulnerability
because 95% of the execution of the thesis
that I just talked about
right here is garbage
and is being done in the
best interest of the partner,
not necessarily your organization.
We live in a very tricky world.
In my thesis of day trading attention,
the Super Bowl is the number
one under-priced asset.
Here I am talking about digital
and crap like machine learning,
and even for B2B companies,
I think the best thing
you could spend money on
is the Super Bowl in North America,
because you know every single American
will know what you have to say
if you actually execute that
30-second spot properly.
It's 100% penetration.
It's under-priced at $7 million a pop.
Meanwhile, a lot of you
spend money on digital,
may spend money on digital.
Most likely not because I was digging,
a lot of sales-driven, we'll
get into that in a minute,
and I believe that
programmatic digital buying
is the most garbage overpriced
marketing in the marketplace
that nobody in this room,
just like they don't consume a commercial,
ever goes to a website and
carefully consumes a banner ad
below the fold and then clicks that banner
and gets into the funnel,
yet billions of dollars being
poured into that environment.
And so what's tricky about it
is in a keynote environment like this,
I can only go top-line.
In reality, there's so much
depth underneath this thesis
in the practitionership,
but what is most important
is understanding what
happens with the next chapter
of companies that own the attention.
Amazon and Google and Facebook and Apple
are not kidding around.
They're building a layer on
top of the internet itself.
The internet is where we live our lives.
This is now secondary,
whether you like it or not,
by the allocation of attention time.
It just is.
This is secondary, and it's
gonna get extreme in a VR world
and for a lot of us, we will never see it,
but you think this is intense?
You think it's bad kids
are on iPads during dinner?
Kids are gonna live in pods in San Diego
and be in the internet 20 hours a day.
We will see that, 20,
30, 40 years once VR,
VR is the only potential
technology at this point
that can arbitrage the
internet out itself.
The majority of this room,
and I'm looking at the faces and the ages
will wear contact lenses that
mix them between real life,
AR, like Santa Claus is giving
the keynote with me right now
or VR, you're just literally
in a different place right now.
And so this phone that seems so intense
and you can't live without
it, this is a pager.
Remember those pagers?
This crew remembers the pager.
As a matter of fact, do
you know there are people
in this room who said they
would never get a mobile device
because their pager was good enough,
and if they needed to get a hold of you,
"I'll get back to you and
I can get back to you"?
So another thing I want to talk about,
because I think it might,
I'm gonna go very high level,
but I do think for this kind of room,
some people will understand this.
This is what I'm spending all my time on,
this is why I believe that
the Alexa and the Google Home
and the Apple Pod are the next arbitrage
and I think a lot of you
should think about this
and this is where sales people
can become disproportionately trained
or arbitraged out completely,
let's talk about it.
At the top of the framework,
the reason I invested in Uber years ago
was not because I thought
they sold transportation,
it was because they sold you back time.
Every person here besides
health, wealth and religion
and their family put time in the pedestal
of the things that
matter to them the most.
You do it every day.
You give up privacy,
you spend tons of money
to arbitrage time.
Uber doesn't sell transportation,
Uber sells the perception of time.
The thing that will sell
the most time back to us
over the next decade will be
voice devices that are smart.
I buy toothpaste now in my bathroom
in one second through Alexa.
I don't make a note,
I don't grab my phone and
buy it on Amazon, I say,
"Alexa, order me toothpaste."
She says, "Sure."
I say, "Buy this", and
the transaction is done.
How many of you have an Amazon Echo or Dot
or a Google Home device in your homes?
Raise your hands.
Great.
Most people are using it
for music, which is nice,
but where this device
is going is staggering.
And the potential is enormous.
I saw a startup the
other day, for example,
that I'm probably gonna
invest in that you say,
"Alexa, I'm reading the
book", you tell 'em the book,
"Jack and Jill", you start
reading the book to your child
and as you're reading, the Alexa is doing
a surround sound narrative
along with you, in unison.
You say, "And then it started raining",
and the whole room
sounds like it's raining.
There will be not a child
on earth in seven years
that will accept a book read to them
without 360 supported sound.
(crowd laughing)
More importantly, the things
that you will do in your car
when you travel when you think
of it to use a voice device
to get it done, reorder your
product, the smartification,
when an IOT device, when
technology is in our food
and it's reordering itself for you,
every person here is going
to have a smart refrigerator
in a decade that reorders the products
in your refrigerator for you.
Amazon's vulnerability is no retailer
that has physical locations.
I don't care what M and
A activity Walmart has,
Amazon's vulnerability is the smart home
that reorders products for you
without you doing it for them.
Toll Brothers is a bigger
competitor to Amazon
if when you buy a new home,
it is stocked with products
that just keep reordering
themselves for you.
When you go into that kitchen
cabinet for the first time
and the toothpaste and
deodorant is picked for you
'cause it's free and
it just reorders itself
when it's being used up,
when your Crest toothpaste
understands you've got
one goddamn squeeze left and
it reorders itself for you
and it comes just as
you're squeezing it out,
you'll start understanding what I mean.
And every person in this room will see it.
My friends, please do me one favor,
and this is the advantage you have
over the 25 year old that gets it,
you underestimated the
internet 13 years ago.
Please take your mental
place back to where it was,
remind yourself of the
embarrassment statements
that you made like the internet itself
is a fad 15 years ago,
that Facebook was a fad and
you would never be on it,
that you would never send an emoji,
please, please understand
that I only have one pitch
and here it is;
I know what you're gonna do before you do
because we like to say
no before we say yes,
but we have no choice.
Now, you live your life how you want.
You know how to parent and grandparent,
you do with your money what you want,
blah blah blah blah blah,
but do not bring that
to the business environment.
Your responsibility as
an executive is to be
100% unemotional on these issues
when it comes to the business environment.
That's what we do.
And so please leave your opinions at home
on what's happening to the human race.
Let me remind you that
Elvis shaking his hips
was once considered a devil move.
Understand this is all evolution.
The robots will kill us in the end,
hopefully not for us to see,
but realize that the
upside of this next decade,
all this conversation I just had,
I'm curious how this is
going through your head
because for me, everything out of my mouth
for the last 20 minutes sets up offense.
The problem is, so many people
are successful, have scale,
and they see defense in
what comes out of my mouth.
You have leverage in the distribution
or the business
architecture you've created,
so this disruption of
that is not interesting
because your leverage
sits in distribution.
The problem is all,
distribution of all kinds
is now commoditized.
And so what you need to
do is what I try to do
every day of my life, I
will go into my office today
and I will try to put
myself out of business.
I will go into my office today
and try to put myself out of business.
I will look at what we do
and I will try to understand
who can come along and kill us
if I don't make the long-term investment.
To make short-term P and L
decisions for your own bonuses,
the stock price, the
board, or what have you
in today's environment is business suicide
because every company has to
make long-term investments
because the C-changes
are so extraordinary.
I run an agency.
We're gonna do $114 million in
revenue this year from zero,
six years ago.
We're gonna make $1.4
million dollars in profit,
triple-checked yesterday, right?
We made $1.3 million in
profit the third year
when we did $6 million.
Why?
Because I'm losing millions of
dollars building capabilities
around voice and machine
learning and AI and messenger
and everything else that
I know in 36 months,
the Pepsis and Coca Colas and Budweisers
and Nikes of the world are gonna need
to have a chance to succeed.
It's not fun for my,
the saddest human on earth is my CFO.
He literally hates his life.
I feel so bad for him,
because I want to give him autonomy
and I respect his position
and I let him do his thing,
and then he gets to the goal line
and I send him all the way back
because this is the only
framework that has success
in today's environment,
the lack of risk and chances
people are taking in here,
even though they know they are right
because of playing for the short-term,
oftentimes for your own
human selfish reasons
because of the timing
of how long you will be
in that position is the
fascinating thing to me
in the business environment today.
Short-term stuff works in the past.
Wall Street dynamics work, bonus
structures work, it worked.
It will not.
And that is why the long-term players
will continue to eat up attention
and deploy anything they want.
Amazon and Google and Apple,
Facebook are not gonna
stop at the things, I mean,
I was so stunned and disappointed
by the collective surprise
of Amazon buying Whole Foods.
I was stunned.
I'm just shocked that so many smart people
were like, "Whoa."
Whoa what?
How do you think this plays out?
Do you know what Chase
Bank's biggest competitor is?
Amazon.
What do you think is happening here?
This is the biggest cultural
shift to the human race
since the printing press
and it magnifies by 10 X.
Do you understand the
ramifications of the Blockchain?
You can talk about Bitcoin
being $10,000 all day long,
that is the pager to
what the Blockchain is.
Blockchain decentralizes the human race.
Blockchain, not Bitcoin, not Ethereum,
Blockchain is something that
Russia, America and China
agree on and will stop
because it's their biggest vulnerability.
Everything in the middle is vulnerable.
All of you are in the middle.
And so now what?
I think what happens is the following.
I'm gonna throw you for a real loop here.
I'm gonna close with this
because I really want to go into Q and A.
Let me set up the Q and A.
The reason I really want to do Q and A is
I've made my statement,
you're gonna have other talks,
I kind of was listening to the agenda,
I'm desperate for people to
ask very basic 101 questions
because my intent when I speak is to get
one or two people to do something.
I have no ambition to get
five, 10, 20, 30% of this room
to act on this thesis,
it's just not practical
in their short-term financial interest,
but if I get one, two, or three,
so for those people that are curious,
please get ready, simple questions.
How does a B2B food service
provider use Facebook
to get an extra account?
I don't care, wherever you want to go.
But before I go there,
I really want to talk about the fact that
the historical legacy stakes are very high
of what I'm talking about,
the compounded nature of
the marketplace is very high
of what I'm talking about.
Here's what I mean by that.
The scale that we now
live in is so extreme.
The ability to go from zero
to a million to 100 million
is so quick because of how much attention
is in these phones.
You have to look at it most practical,
this gentleman here
with the nice yellow tie
is working while this is happening.
This is just, which I'm
cool with, do your thing--
(crowd laughing)
But it's fun for me, right?
Because you have to understand
how incredible that is.
That is not something we
could all do 15 years ago,
there's just, I'm trying to
really push through here,
please, stop underestimating.
Stop underestimating.
You have sales staff?
How many people here have sales staff?
Raise your hands.
Great, let me talk to you
what I think you should do.
You should start an internal podcast
that you program every week
that is made for your sales team
because the toolkits and
the PDFs and the emails
and the off-sites and awarding one guy
the good thing he did
that we all want you to do
a year award at the end is
not doing what you need.
But, they are on the move.
They are consuming content
at scale in their car.
They can listen to your
podcast which is internal
and all 1,600 of them can listen,
and you can push propaganda
down their throat 24/7
if you understand how to give them value
in 60% of the content,
entertainment, escapism,
something that benefits them
so that you can subtly bring in yours in.
I believe that the businesses in this room
have to take a page out of something
that has been done historically
by companies like the
Michelin Tire Company
and Guinness Beers Company.
I believe the people in
this room that understand
that they are now a media
company first, comma,
and then whatever comes out of your mouth
or is on your business card
that you will have the
framework of success
for the next decade.
Let me explain.
I believe that if you understand
why the Michelin Tire
Company 100 years ago
decided to start reviewing
villas and hotels and restaurants
throughout Europe because
they wanted people
to start driving and using up their cars
and stopping at their
stations and getting gas,
and more importantly, changing tires,
they started pumping propaganda,
a guide in the cities of London and Paris
which remarkably and coincidentally
scored all the best foie
gras and champagne lists
40 miles outside the city,
and forced people to go and see what this
three-star chateau was,
and they used a media property to create
the business behavior that they wanted,
that the Guinness Book came out because
Guinness was losing market share in pubs,
but knew that people talked
about trivia and fun facts
in the pubs through their market research
and created the Guinness
Book of World Records
because they would hope
that you would talk about
a 17-foot man, and then the Guinness brand
would be reinforced and it
would come out of your mouth
at the pub.
These are two historically
unbelievably successful
media executions.
My belief is that if
you actually understood
in the same way that it
is impossible for you
to not have a CFO or a controller,
it is impossible for you
not to have a head of sales,
I believe for most of your organizations
in the next five to 10 years,
it will be impossible for you not to have
an editor-in-chief of your business.
You are not at the mercy of
the in-between media companies,
you can go direct.
You can start the most meaningful podcast.
You can start the most
meaningful podcast tomorrow
for all the franchisee
owners of every QSR company
in America by giving them information
that makes them run their business better,
and then use all of
that attention to deploy
what you want to accomplish
in your business.
You can.
It's super far-fetched, it
doesn't feel comfortable,
but it didn't feel
comfortable for the executives
at the Nintendo Company
to switch from being
a playing card company
to a board game company
to a video game company.
The evolution that is needed
in the strategies in this room
when it comes to marketing
and sales are extraordinary.
They're extraordinary.
And please do not rely
on what got you here.
It's exactly what is
not going to allow you
to get to the next stage.
So that's where I'm at, that's
what I'm thinking about.
I want to put a couple more points on,
and where are the runners for the Q and A?
Just got a couple?
Okay, awesome, just raise
your hands in a second,
just looking at the timing.
I'll leave with this, and
then we'll do some Q and A,
we'll take it from there.
And please think about your question.
Much bigger, better companies than yours
went out of business.
It's history.
And what is happening
now to the infrastructure
of our society is something
we're gonna have to navigate,
so please check your audacity at the door,
nobody cares about your
contracts or your history.
It's your vulnerability.
Thank you.
(crowd applauding)
- [Woman] I'm gonna help you
sort of find our question.
- Awesome, who's got a question?
- [Woman] Do we have anybody?
Oh, we've got lots of hands.
- Yeah.
- [Woman] All right, we'll
start out over there.
- It's the greatest
keynote I've ever given.
Hey.
- Very interesting.
Thank you very much.
- What's your name?
- [Roy] Oh, Roy Foster.
- Roy.
- [Roy] I'm curious with
your mindset right now
where to take your marketing spin.
- Yes.
- [Roy] How do you see
that potentially shifting
with repeal of net neutrality?
- That's a super great question.
Roy, one thing, you can see I can peacock
with the best of them.
I hate to answer stuff that
I haven't fully quantified.
I'm spending a ton of
time of trying to play
not only the short, look,
guys like me and gals like me,
there's a lot to be said,
like screw you, the tollbooth,
this is terrible.
I'm a funny, it's so funny,
maybe I'm intense capitalism
because I was born in communism
and I'm so fascinated by the countermove.
Let's say it plays through.
What next?
Cool, so the ISPs are this,
but why can't Facebook
and Google and Apple
arbitrage that out by deploying all,
great, everything gets overcharged, great.
You have Verizon and they give you Yahoo,
blistering fast for free,
but Google costs $50 a month.
Something a lot of people
here have not quantified
their head around that
is a very real statement,
and I mean like this, right?
Everybody's like, with
little headline readings,
like Matt Lauer and this and this,
everybody's paying
attention to so many things,
you wake up and in 18 months,
you're paying $50 a month
for the right to use Google.
That's like, what the
hell just happened, right?
But here's what's funny about the game.
What happens next is
more interesting, right?
As they start getting fat,
the people that are getting
commoditized by them and hurt
have the ability to arbitrage them out.
And by the way, I'm so pumped,
I'm so thrilled you
brought up that question.
That's my biggest fear here.
There's a lot of people
here who play in the ISP,
net neutrality environment
in their business.
They think they've got it locked up,
until their customer's out of business,
until their customer's
being squeezed so much
by the innovators of Tesla
or Facebook or Amazon
that they have to start
changing their business model,
and they don't want you
to make profit anymore.
It's not about is Walmart or
McDonald's go out of business,
is it that they are losing enough business
that they don't want you
to make a penny ever again.
So what do I think?
I think day trading attention
is something I'd become committed to,
which is I think about it
when it becomes the reality
and I just do it immediately.
I spend time trying to be
thoughtful about these things.
You can't predict a lot of things.
I made a video nine months ago that said
Instagram was in trouble
because Snapchat was exploding.
Facebook's much younger than people think.
A week later, and they copied
everything of Snapchat,
and they're the disproportionate
most important platform to market
if you care about consumers
25 to 40 in North America.
So I think it's potentially
annoying, potentially dangerous,
feels really not fun, but
there's places that have it.
You can look at what
Portugal's market looks like,
but I don't think they're
ready to pay 11 bucks a month
for Facebook being the speed it is now
versus it being free, but taking an hour.
Do you know how mad everybody gets here
when their internet is
100th of a second slower
than what they're accustomed to?
Right?
I mean so I think it's a
very interesting tollbooth
and I'm excited to watch it play out,
but I don't get crippled on what if.
I'm more worried than everybody here's
wasting money right now, tomorrow.
And that's why when people
talk about VR and AR,
or it's changing or it's
coming, I'm like, no, no no,
what are you doing today?
Where was your money,
do you know you know what's fun
is not being at the mercy of sales people
and their commissions and
structures and bonuses.
Brand, have the leverage.
Brand is the only leverage we have.
Questions?
We've got a gentlemen here.
- Let's go--
- Yeah.
- To that same table.
- Okay, same table.
How are you?
- [Woman] Good, thank you.
- [Gary] What's your name?
- I'm Annie.
- Annie.
- [Annie] I have a question.
How do you, can you hear me?
- Yes.
- [Annie] How do you translate taste?
Which is key to what we do food and Ag.
How do you translate that on the internet
or through virtual reality
or whatever the format is?
- The historic translator
of taste that over-indexes
is called video.
A human being articulates
through a visual and words
what they are experiencing
and we consume it, right?
None of this stuff is any
different than anything happens.
The same thing that Julia
Childs did, that Emeril did,
that many other things have been done
is being done now by somebody on Instagram
in a one-minute video.
I think everything is translated
through three core things;
Audio, video, and the written word.
The end.
How everybody consumes
information here is different,
the historical upside is in video.
It's the biggest penetrator of our psyche.
I would say video, but where and how much?
You can make an $800,000
video that is a commercial
on television on the Food Network
that not a soul will watch, in my opinion.
You can make a YouTube video in 2006
when nobody else was doing it
and get a tremendous land grab.
I think about attention like real estate.
I want you to buy beachfront
property in Malibu
63 years ago, right?
Not overpriced real estate on the
Meatpacking District in Manhattan.
And I think that's what
the majority of people do
because it's tried and
true without understanding
how overpriced it is.
- [Woman] We have another
question over here.
- Over there, great.
Who's got it?
Let's go.
- Down the center there.
- Okay.
How are you?
- [Nick] Very well, that was a
quite frightening, thank you.
Nick from Rabobank.
Two things.
One, why Facebook, why not
Instagram, whatever, Twitter?
And also you talk a lot about attention,
and we keep hearing
that the attention span
of people is getting shorter and shorter
so how do you maintain their attention?
- So when I talk about Facebook,
you can hold the mic for a second,
'cause this might be a follow-up,
Facebook and Instagram,
owned by the same company.
When I talk, it's a nuance
of the business talk,
I do want to talk Instagram.
Facebook, because it's scale.
So the highest conversion selling stuff
that I know in the world is 60
to 80 year olds on Facebook.
Not conventional wisdom,
not the headlines you read,
but as a practitioner,
there's a lot of nuances
to figuring out why it's
been working for me.
Number one, a 72 year old on Facebook
goes through their
Facebook stream like this.
(crowd laughing)
A 17 year old goes through
that same stream like this.
It's just attention arbitrage, right?
So Facebook, 'cause of its scale.
Instagram's on its way,
but Instagram plays 15 to
let's say 45, 50 on the coasts,
it plays 15 to 35 in the middle,
Facebook is 25 because
it's not winning under--
- [Nick] The minute I got on Facebook,
my daughter got off it.
- That's exactly right.
It's classic cops and robbers, right?
And now parents are getting on Instagram,
and they're looking elsewhere,
and Snapchat more 'cause it disappeared.
We've all been there.
We've all locked our room,
we all wanted a second phone line,
we all understand that dynamic.
That to me is like secondary fodder.
I just want to know
where the attention is.
Facebook is so ridiculously under-priced.
Let me explain.
You will pay seven dollars to
get in front of 1,000 people
which 13 will actually see it,
'cause they'll go through it,
but you're gonna pay $58 for
that same thing in four years.
That's all.
I don't know else to say.
If you've ever run a
Google AdWords campaign,
the word wine cost me five
cents a click one day,
it now costs me $14 a click.
Marketplaces are supply and demand,
which means there's
vulnerabilities in them.
Attention spans, there's a lot
of conversations around this.
First of all, it's old talk audacity.
We love to say new people
are not as good as us
because we're getting
older and closer to the end
and it's our defense, right?
We love to talk about the
Millennials' entitlement.
90% of the people I know that
I grew up with in their 40s
were lazy and entitled too.
(crowd laughing and applauding)
- [Nick] That's just Americans, isn't it?
- Yeah.
(crowd laughing)
You know it's funny, there's
a lot of truth to that,
but that's a hell of a
lot better than Europeans
who aren't even in the game.
(crowd laughing and applauding)
By the way, the Chinese
are gonna kill everybody
because that's the way you,
by the way, you know
what's crazy about China?
They run their country the
way we run our businesses.
Our businesses are
capitalistic with dictatorship.
It's really funny to
watch it all play out.
Nonetheless, I'm not worried
about attention spans
because I like when things are all equal.
It's back to net neutrality.
As long as every other
person I'm competing with
is dealing with the same
ramifications then I'm cool, right?
And I think that's the part
that's making it so interesting.
As the technologies advance,
we get put into more of a
playing field that's equal
which takes away a lot of the advantages
we had historically, and that's the rub.
Retail didn't need to go out of business.
We just need to do enough
more retail on e-commerce
to break their whole model
'cause it lowered just enough,
the sales, where the
infrastructure costs of real estate
and all the things in the
real estate environment,
fixtures and people broke the model,
so you don't need a lot
to stress the system.
Attention spans are tremendous
if you give people something
they want to watch.
I see people watching 47
minute videos on Facebook
and not watching six second videos.
The quality of the content
is the differentiator,
not the length.
You want to pass it behind you?
How are you?
- I'm great and--
- Thank you.
- [Man] And thank you.
Some of the things that you
said, absolutely eye-opening.
- [Gary] Like what?
- [Man] So for example the concept like--
- [Gary] No really, I'm
curious, what hit you?
- [Man] The concept of
Facebook advertising
or using Facebook or B2B--
- It's like, right?
- To me was brand new.
- I get it.
- I've always thought about it
as consumer-facing, it
used to be consumer-facing,
but from a B2B standpoint,
it was a little bit eye-opening
for me and hopefully--
- And I have some great news.
It's for you and everybody
else in the environment.
Most companies literally think it's better
to spend $47,000 on a
print ad in a B2B magazine
that nobody opens then
spend $10,000 to test
how Facebook could work for them.
Utter audacity, nothing else.
- [Man] So again, eye-opening for me.
Also, thank you for inviting
us to ask very basic questions.
So I'd actually appreciate
if you could elaborate
a little bit more on an example
you gave of does your CEO--
- Let's talk about your business.
Who are you trying to reach?
- [Man] So we're a food
and greeting company.
- Okay.
- And so we have
manufacturers of food products.
For example, we have,
we're developing some
very special ingredients.
We'd probably love to be able to develop
some sort of Intel Inside type concept--
- Love that, I understand.
- [Man] We're a middle market company,
so our ability to spend
massive dollars to do that
as Intel can is not there.
- Yes.
- [Man] But the
concept-defining strategies
that can help us do that is fascinating.
- And they didn't have it either, right?
When you have the ingredient
that every consumer-facing
product is proud to put
on the front of their package,
they'll do it for you.
Your problem is you need
to actually build a brand.
You need to make the, how many people
are aware of what happened
with the Dollar Shave Club?
I assume a lot of you are, right?
Raise your hands, I'm just
trying to get context.
So Dollar Shave Club made
a video that went viral
and sold their company
for one billion dollars
in four years.
There's nothing else really there.
They did it, but by the way,
so did Nike with Just Do
It, and so did MasterCard
for a 15 year period with Priceless.
You make a video that we all get by it,
Wendy's had a moment in the 80s,
it was called Where's The Beef?
It works.
The fact that you could
actually make a three minute,
13 second video of a mom and a daughter
and they have a healthier
life because of your product
and the other part of
the three minute video
showed if they had not had
your product, they wouldn't,
and that just strikes a chord,
or the Ice Bucket Challenge,
the fact that you can spend
$100,000 to make a video
and another $50,000 to 100 to spend on ads
against the potential demo
to create the groundswelling
to then drive back to
give you the leverage
with the consumer packaged good companies
so that they come to you
to put the greeting in
instead of you begging, whoever
asks gives up the leverage.
I can't believe we live in a
world where you have a chance
for that $200,000 to have
Procter and Gamble and Unilever
and Coca Cola actually reach out to you.
That is mind-boggling.
Now, I'm not here to sell fairy dust.
20 out of 21 of those efforts could lose,
but four may be singles.
Dollar Shave Club was a grand slam.
Four of those videos maybe singles.
20 may be strikeouts, and then
you just wasted two million,
this is practical, but
the fact that 10 of them
can be double, singles, triples,
and as we start getting
smarter about the creative
that actually gets people to
watch, it's an incredible time
to be in business, you know?
It is absolutely frightening,
like the gentleman said,
but it's also unbelievably incredible.
You just can't hold on to
the romance of the strategies
and leverage that you had or
have or that you overpaid for
just recently, it just
doesn't work that way,
that's why people go out of business.
So what I would do, if you're
trying to be Intel Inside,
you actually have to win consumer.
So you have to make the emotional creative
to get the Millennial mom
or the 50 year old male
or whoever your target demo
is to actually start demanding
or getting excited about this ingredient
that will make them live.
I'm super fascinated by cricket
protein for example, right?
So I think I'm bullish on cricket protein,
there's just a lot there,
it's just a very easy
narrative for me to sell
and everything you just heard,
I just have to make people
excited about eating crickets.
(crowd laughing)
But you know what's more
difficult than that?
Convincing people 40 years
ago to pay for water,
'cause it was free.
So, that.
And while it's four dollars to
get in front of 1,000 people
and not 63, got it?
That's why I'm excited.
That's what this energy
is, because I'm so thrilled
that 94% of this room is
gonna wake up in six years,
read an article how the
years of 2013 to 2018
were the best years to build on Facebook,
and all these big companies came out of it
and I want them to remember
this talk and be super pissed
they didn't listen to me.
(crowd laughing)
I mean it, historically
correct, that's my currency.
- Thank you.
- You got it.
- [Woman] Looks like we
have another hand down--
- Yeah, right next to you.
And let, right side, what up?
(crowd laughing)
Let's get going over there.
Somebody's got to step up for that side.
- [Ken] Hi, Ken Zuckerberg.
- Hey, Ken.
- Fascinating discussion.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Ken] Are we, since
this room has a lot of
sort of businesses that are traditional,
are we at the end of the
day talking about disruption
of distribution, the middleman?
- Yes, yes we are.
- I mean that's a key message
I got here, and I guess
if you could explain when
we have people that are
manufacturing product,
selling a traditional
channel to a consumer,
obviously a lot of B2B,
how do you help the CEOs
and the senior managements
embrace this in a way that they can then
have the action rate at
95%, not 4% or 3% then?
- With the success of the creative?
- Yeah.
- You can't.
Which is what's so difficult, right?
Creative is the variable of
success and it's very difficult.
I've been spending the last seven years
in trying to close the gap.
The way you can do it is
by driving down the cost
of the creative.
If you have $500,000 to spend
and you only get one chance
to try, you'll lose, and
so what I've been doing
is building over the last seven years
the ability to give you
11 at-bats for that price
at the same quality of just one.
- [Ken] So your thinking
is 10 standard deviations
quicker than most of us.
I mean, it's inspiring, it's terrific.
- Thank you.
- [Ken] When you bring it back to--
- Reality?
- [Ken] Reality, think
about a chemicals company,
think about an ingredients company,
how do you make that initial,
how do you make that initial step?
And I--
- It's very simple.
It's a religious step, right?
Or a functional step.
To your point, it's what
I've been fascinated by,
getting into bigger business environments,
coming from entrepreneurship
in Silicon Valley
through radical things like firing the CEO
or scaring them or inspiring them.
You can't play in the middle.
Or what really needs to happen,
which is changing the
way we incentivize them.
I can't blame you, I used to
be so mad at these people,
like, "You are such jerks,
"you just care about the
stock price being good
"in three years so when you leave,
"you buy a yacht, you
piece of crap", right?
That's what I thought.
I still weirdly think that,
but I'm way more empathetic
that the structure of the whole game
has put you in that position.
But here's the really
important part of the question.
I have unbelievable empathy,
but what I try to remind
people on a one-to-one
who've really gotten to know
me, or in this environment is
it's going to happen, it's
happened, it's happening,
so why I'm so fascinated about marketing
is 'cause I know a lot of people here,
if they spend any money on marketing
are putting it directly in the garbage.
And so by taking it out of the garbage
and whether it's a $100,000 or $3 million,
spending that right starts
giving people in here
the confidence of wait a
minute, why did that work?
And then you start building on it.
We've gone from places where
Ruby Tuesdays and Mondelez
where it went from being 1%
of the way they did things
to 40%, not 'cause they
liked me or I was charismatic
or I'm clever, because of results.
So you try every different angle.
I've been in this B2B environment.
91% of my clients don't do it
the way that I want them to.
I'm trying to be historically
correct, and more importantly,
my entire thesis as to why I'm buying,
I'm building VaynerMedia to become
a consumer packaged goods holding company.
I want to build the
next Procter and Gamble
on the back of building the next WPP,
and I went in because I thought 3G
was gonna be over compensated
and heralded in the last decade,
which clearly, they have,
but you can only fire so many people.
You have to build top-line
revenue and brand.
And so nobody's ever built the complement,
I am building the complement
for ever Carlisle and Bain
and Carl Icahn and Bill Ackman on earth,
I'm in the process of it,
which is why I can see this.
I'm being very patient,
I'm eating my own dog food
that I'm trying to get you to,
which is run a marathon, not a sprint,
because you don't realize the sprint game
is not even gonna be in,
it's not gonna be in the Olympics anymore.
Do you understand?
That's the problem.
And so how do you do it?
You suffocate them, right?
I mean it.
You suffocate the decision
maker, through sheer will,
through frightening, through inspiring,
through data, I don't know,
but you have the actual conversation.
Let's get that dude
all the way over there.
He went far right.
- Oh yeah.
Right side of the room.
- Love it.
It's binary, right?
I can give you a million new, it's binary,
they either decide to do it or not,
but marketing is the most movable thing.
(crowd member speaking quietly)
I'll repeat it for everybody.
My brother, I invested, I
bought Mark's parents shares
in 2008 on a discount on a
valuation that was $10 billion,
and I put every dollar
I had in liquid into it.
My financial advisor, my
parents, my contemporaries,
my mentors, they shit on me, right?
Next, it went public.
All my friends because I was
an early investor and advocate,
all my friends that were
the top 100 employees there,
90% of them sold 90% of
their holdings between 12,
excuse me, 19 and $40 a share,
depending on their timing.
Six month, you know?
I bought it in 2008, I
haven't sold one share.
I bought Twitter, back to your question,
I never fully finished
answering it, why not Twitter?
I bought Twitter at the same time.
A $47,000 investment that
was worth $16 million to me,
and I sold 90% of my holding
at $44, it's $20 now,
because I just day trade attention.
I'm not emotional.
The end.
You want to make a lot of money?
Put all your liquid
into Facebook and Amazon
that you can never touch.
As long as Jeff Bezos and
Mark Zuckerberg are alive
and running it, you will win.
Guys, this hasn't started yet.
The shrug is 'cause it hasn't started.
I love how people think disruption,
everything you see being
disrupted right now,
tier three auto.
How does a car dealership
survive in the 40-year macro
when Tesla goes direct to consumer?
Because the government and the
laws are gonna protect you?
For how long?
It's just naivete and
short-term thinking at scale.
- [Man] Thanks, it's been
eye-opening for me as well.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Man] You've talked a lot
about day trading attention
between B2B and B2C, but as a bank,
we're also sort of a
middleman, to a certain extent.
- [Gary] You're in deep shit too.
(crowd laughing)
- So,
apart from hosting you at our conference
and being the keynote
speaker, what can we do?
- I think you need to look
things in the eye, right?
You need to actually not say,
and you can't be in
conferences like this and say,
in a more conservative
environment and say,
"Over the next 10 years
Amazon or Venmo or Blockchain
"are disruptive or
potentially disruptive",
it's really no different,
it's gonna be the same answer
for everybody at that scale.
Banks have to realize
what their value prop is
and how quickly it's being commoditized.
And it's happening fast, right?
So I think it's about creating
new products and services.
I think it's about M and A activity
and grossly overpaying for things
that look like you're overpaying for them.
I was on CNN the day after
Facebook bought Instagram.
They paid a billion dollars.
Instagram was 551 days
old and Piers Morgan goes,
"Okay Gary Vee, what do you think?"
And I go, "They stole it."
I get out of the studio in
Columbus Circle and 10,000 people
on Twitter tell me I'm an idiot
because they'd never heard of it,
and a billion dollars sure
sounds like a lot of money.
By the way, side note, I
favorited every one of them
and two years later on a
trip to Turks and Caicos,
I went back and replied to all of them
and said, "Now what?"
(crowd laughing)
I think the biggest thing the
biggest companies here can do
is grossly overpay for the future,
but they have to be right.
But that's what they need to do.
You need to buy up other services
if you believe what I believe.
And I could be wrong,
I've been wrong before,
but the core of what a
bank does at its essence
is being disrupted very quickly.
You do not put Blockchain back in the bag.
It may not happen,
Bitcoin could go to zero.
That's irrelevant.
You have an entire
generation that understands
the decentralization of us
interacting with each other.
When you understand that
you are gonna close a house
on Ethereum, between me and
you, and we will accept that,
it goes into a totally different place.
I think people are very naive.
They don't understand
how religion happened.
That's what I think.
Sir.
Yes.
- [Man] Yes, so I'm
gonna almond processor--
- [Gary] Oh, I'm sorry,
where's this coming from?
- Right here.
- Where?
- In the--
- Oh, hey sorry.
Okay, we'll do you quickly as well
then we'll get out of here,
I don't want to run too late.
- [Man] We're an almond processing company
that exports to 70 different countries.
Do you expect Amazon to accept Bitcoin
and how will that affect the marketplace?
- I believe cryptocurrencies
crossed over the chasm.
I expect China, Russia and America
to have a whole lot of say on this issue
and I don't know how the
citizens in our world
will react to it.
So I don't know.
You know why I love what I do up here?
I don't guess.
Everything you've heard so far is fact.
You just don't see it.
That's me guessing.
My intuition is Jeff
Bezos wants to dominate
at such a scale,
he has such internal ambition for legacy
that he'll go as hard
and as fast as he can
at disrupting everybody
as long as the governments allow him to.
But you know this by playing in 70,
European DNA versus US DNA
versus China, you gotta,
you're gonna have fragmentation at scale.
Just like you've seen
from Google and Facebook,
everybody create closed gardens.
What do you think America's
trying to do right now?
And you're gonna see
some reactions to that,
so we have to figure that out.
- Thank you.
Sir?
- [Man] You talked about
the importance of brand.
We've seen brands that were
icons that have tarnished
and new brands come out of nowhere.
What are the most
important values in a brand
that you look for or see?
- The biggest reason big
brands get tarnished,
AKA, irrelevant, is 'cause they take money
and put it directly in the garbage, right?
The reason the biggest
brands are losing right now
is 'cause they think
running television ads
is worth their 70% of the
allocation of their money.
The end.
This is historical.
You want to really learn
something if you're a nerd?
Go look what happened in
the late 40s and early 50s
when we transitioned from
a primary radio society
to a primary television society.
The biggest brands in
the world died, right?
Because they went to the club
with the guy that sold him radio.
Misjudging where people
are paying attention,
this keynote has content, right?
Whether you like this or
not, this was content.
If nobody was in this hall right now,
it would have been a bad use of my time.
That's how brands lose.
And there's another part.
They become vulnerable to the person
that's closest to the consumer.
In 1982, the biggest supermarkets
and super stores in this country
basically got zero trade dollars
from the biggest brands in the world.
And Pillsbury and Kellogg's
and everybody else
was able to spend all
their money on marketing.
As Walmart and Albertsons
and Publix got smarter
and started making people
pay for shelf space,
support their internal ad
networks and everything else,
they started taking money
out of the suppliers
and putting it into their own pockets.
And then it became a drug,
because it was great for short-term sales,
and then they took that drug money
and started creating private labels
and commoditized the biggest
brands out of the world,
while then the biggest brands in the world
still spent money on television
because the biggest media
companies in the world
push television down their throat
with bullshit metrics
from Nielsen's and others
because that's where the margin is
for the biggest holding
companies in the media world,
leaving brands like Pillsbury Doughboy
and Tony the Tiger left for dead.
Got it?
(crowd laughing)
Thank you.
(crowd applauding)
Let's end it with this.
Who are you sending this keynote to?
Leave a comment in the
section, and subscribe.
(uptempo music)